in the last video we showed that if you
had a line which we'll call a directrix
we draw the directrix
that's our directrix and has the
equation y is equal to K and you have a
point that's our focus and it's the
coordinate a comma B that the locus of
all points in the XY plane that are
equidistant to this focus and this
directrix has a shape that looks
something we know that this was a point
that looks something like this and it's
actually equation we actually just took
an arbitrary X Y in the coordinate plane
and we said that X Y has to satisfy the
condition that its distance to this
focus is equal to that this distance
right here is equal to this distance
here and we set that up using the
distance formula here and then setting
that equal to the distance to the line
to the directrix and then we did a bunch
of algebra and we got this equation
right here for the for all of the points
in the XY plane that satisfy the
conditions that its distance to the
focus is equal to the distance to this
line and we hopefully satisfied
ourselves that this is a this is in fact
a parabola and although it looks a
little bit hairier than most parabola as
we see it I think if you look at it
closer you'll read that it is indeed a
parabola for example this is a you know
the classic parabola is y is equal to x
squared how is this the same thing as
this well in this case this coefficient
out here is just equal to 1 right so in
this case 1 over 1 over 2 B minus K is
equal to 1 right let me delete that
little thing there because it looks like
a squared right the coefficient in front
of the x squared term is equal to a 1
what is a equal to what's this a equal
to well there's X minus this is the same
thing as this is the same thing actually
let me write it that way I could rewrite
this equation right here as Y minus 0 is
equal to 1 times X minus 0 squared and
now hopefully you see that this has the
same pattern
this although the why's that the exes
are just sitting on different sides of
the equation so here you see that the
one-half over B minus K that's the
coefficient in front of the X minus a
squared term so that's where we got that
that has to be equal to one if we a a
has to be equal to zero a is equal to
zero in this situation so this a is
going to be equal to zero if this curve
right here is equal to x squared y is
equal to x squared a is zero and then B
plus K over 2 this is going to be equal
to that and just keep in mind I actually
switched swap the left and the right
side sides but this is the Y minus
something this is Y minus 0 so this
something has to be equal to zero so you
get B plus K over two is equal to zero
and now we should be able to use this
information to figure out the actual
coordinates of the focus and the
directrix of the what I would call the
classic parabola y is equal to x squared
so keep in mind what we did in the last
video we said what is the equation of
the line that is equidistant between
this focus and this directrix and we got
this equation which we said hey that's a
parabola now we're going the other way
around we say we have a parabola and
we're saying that this parabola is
equidistant it's the set of all points
that equal that's equidistant between
some focus and some directrix
what is that focus and that directrix
for this particular parabola that's what
we're trying to do and the way we did
that is we pattern match this formula or
this formula to this one to essentially
set up these these variables which
essentially define a focus in a paren a
directrix right B is the y coordinate of
the focus K is the defines the
horizontal line of the directrix so if
we can solve for B and K we know what
the focus in the directrix are and for a
although a is pretty easy so let's do
that so if we know that 1 over 2 B minus
K is equal to 1 let me do that over here
now I'm going to it particularly for
this case right here but you don't want
to do that every time so then we'll
we'll do a more Jen
a formula that we can just plug in next
time you see a new parabola so if we say
one oh if we multiply both sides of this
equation by to be minus K you get 1 is
equal to 2 times B minus K let's see
actually I should well let's just divide
by both sides by 2 so you get 1/2 is
equal to B minus K fair enough see this
equation right here if B plus K over 2
is equal to 0 that means that B plus K
must be equal to 0 right this numerator
has to be equal to 0 so let me write
that down B plus K is equal to 0 to 2
linear equations of two unknowns let's
add them up the KS cancel out you get 2
B is equal to 1/2 divide both sides by 2
you get B is equal to 1/4 and now what's
K well we could just resub stitute back
we could let's use this equation we get
0 is equal to 1/4 plus K well you can
look figure that out by inspection but
you can subtract 1/4 from both sides so
this tells us that K is equal to minus
1/4 so let's draw this so if this is my
coordinate axis I'll do it in a
different color that's the x-axis that's
the y-axis we're dealing with X is y is
equal to x squared which you should
hopefully be reasonably familiar with at
this point it's kind of the classic
u-shaped parabola that looks just like
that we write that down so this is y is
equal to x squared which we could have
rewritten as Y minus 0 is equal to 1
times X minus 0 squared same thing
that's this line it's equidistant from a
focus and a directrix where this is the
focus and how do I know that the focus
is right there instead of right here
right there well 1 you could you could
kind of think about it but the other
thing to realize is if this is what is
the vertex of this parabola and I think
we've gone over
ready but the vertex are the coordinates
given by this x value and this Y value
or what X values make this whole term 0
and make this whole term 0 and that's
essentially 0 0 so this is the vertex of
this parabola this is the vertex it's 0
0 is the vertex I'll say V for vertex
that's in an upward and an upward
opening parabola you can kind of view
that as the minimum point it was the
downward opening it would be the topmost
point or the maximum point so that's the
vertex and we saw from when we solve
this when we just did our pattern
matching that the x-coordinate of our of
our focus is equivalent to if we just
pattern match right here X minus a
squared here you have X minus 0 squared
this is always going to be the same as
this so the x-coordinate of our vertex
is always I'm sorry the x-coordinate of
our focus is always going to be the same
thing as the x-coordinate of our vertex
so we figured out that a was equal to 0
so the coordinate here is 0 and then
what's B right this was the coordinate 0
B we figured out B is equal to 1/4 0 1/4
and then the directrix is the line y is
equal to K in this case we figure out K
is equal to minus 1/4 so our directrix
is going to be right down here right
down here like that and it's going to be
the line y is equal to minus 1/4 and
that first of all looks about right and
it also gels with what we know because
this point right here our vertex is
equidistant it's 1/4 below our focus and
it's 1/4 above our directrix so at least
at that little reality check holds but
this was a particular circumstance and
you don't want to have to go through
this whole situation every time you have
to figure out the focus or the directrix
of a parabola so let's see if we can
come up with a more a more general
solution and actually what I'm going to
do is I'm going to erase all of this
just because I want to reuse that and I
haven't
committed that formula to heart yet let
me erase all of this and let me erase
all the work we did down here so let's
do a general form and actually I've I've
kind of abused this so much let me
rewrite it so this and I'll put the Y's
on the left-hand side and so instead of
keep telling you that I've switched them
so this is the same thing as do it in
I'll do it in the color choosing is the
hard part I'll do it in this light
off-white color so you get Y minus B
plus K over 2 is equal to 1 over 2 times
B minus K times X minus a squared this
is the locus of all all points that are
between the directrix Y is equal to K
and the oh that are equidistant to the
directrix Y is equal to K and the focus
a comma B so let's say that I have a
parabola and I'm going to try to use
different letters so we don't get
confused I'm give you the parabola Y
minus y1 and let's say this parabola has
a vertex at x1 comma Y y1 so this
parabola I'm drawing has a vertex right
there so it's form will be Y minus y1 is
equal to some constant let's call make
that a capital a this capital a is
different than that lowercase a this is
what I was going to embark on in the
previous video and then I realized that
I was trying to load that video up too
much and probably confusing you so some
constant factor some some type of
scaling factor times X minus the x value
of our vertex so x1
all of that squared so if you're given
this parabola or if you can get a
parabola to this form how do you figure
out the A's the bees and the K so you
know the coordinate of the directrix and
the focus so the easy thing is to figure
out a because you just do a pattern
match
this is going to be equal to that so you
know that a is equal to x1 so the
x-coordinate of our focus is the same as
the x-coordinate of our vertex you can
pattern match that this scaling factor
right here is going to be the same thing
as this 1 over 2 B minus K so let's
write that down
a is equal to 1 over 2 B minus K and
then we have finally this let me do
another color to magenta the B plus K
over 2 we have Y minus that thing we
have Y minus y1 so that's going to be
equal to y1 so you have y1 is equal to B
plus K over 2 and now we have two
equations with two unknowns remember
this is this is going to be a given the
a is going to be given and the y1 is
going to be given so now we can solve
for B and K in terms of the numbers that
we have so let's see if we can do that
so if we multiply both sides of this
equation times B minus K you get B minus
K times a is equal to 1/2 divide both
sides by a you get B minus K is equal to
1 over 2a and on the right hand side
let's use this other formula right here
if we multiply both sides by 2 under a
different color you get 2 times y1 is
equal to B plus K two equations with two
unknowns let's take this and bring it
down here so you get B plus K is equal
to 2 times y1 and so you add them and
you get 2 B is equal to the KS cancel
out I'm just adding these two equations
1 over 2a plus 2y 1 or B which is
remember what was B that was the
y-coordinate of our focus is equal to
divide everything by 2 is equal to 1
over 4a plus y1 which is interesting it
tells us that whatever the it's
we take the the y coordinate of our
vertex and we add 1 over 4a to it which
is exactly what happened last time right
oh I actually erased that what I did
last time but last time when we had y
equal x squared this value was 0 the at
the scaling factor was 1 so we saw that
the y coordinate of our focus was 1/4 so
this is this is gelling with what we
know so that's our B that's our B and
let's see if we can solve back for K so
we know we know that let's do it up here
we know that 2y 1 is equal to B which is
1 over 4a plus y 1 plus K we can
subtract Y 1 from both sides so this
goes away and you just have a y1 there
subtract 1 over 4a from both sides and
you get y1 minus 1 over 4a is equal to K
so then we are done
so this is interesting right now these
these might look a little these little
hairy formulas but if we actually graph
it I think they'll become a little bit
more intuitive so once again we had the
parabola Y minus y1 is equal to a times
X minus x1 squared and so the graph of
that parabola will look something like
this I don't know where it is relative
to the X and the y-axis it'll look
something like this it'll be this
u-shape I mean it could actually be
downward it could actually be downward
pointing but I'll just assume an upward
pointing parabola for now that's this
formula it's vertex right there its
vertex is the point x1 comma y1 right
what Y value makes this expression
equals 0 its y1 what x value makes that
equal 0 its x1 now notice what is this
directrix it's the line K y equal to K
but it's it's 1/4 less than this value
right here so you literally just go down
1/4 not just 1/4 1/4 time
aimes this Kaling factor so it's 1/4 a
this distance is 1/4 a and then you get
your directrix right it's y1 minus 1/4 a
is equal to K y1 minus 1/4 a is equal to
K or 1 over 4a so your directrix is
going to be right right there let me
write this is y is equal to y1 which is
just this level minus 1 over 4a but this
is the intuitive part just remember
you're going 1 over 4a or 1 over 4a
below the vertex and then the focal
point the x-value of the focal point is
going to be x1 the same is the x-value
of the vertex and then we go the
y-values this b and we just go 1 over 4a
above it which makes sense because we
need to be equidistant from the
directrix in the focus so this is why 1
plus 1 over 4a but the intuitive part is
we just took 1 over 4a above it right so
in general if I gave you so just think
about this a second if I gave you an
equation an arbitrary equation now let's
say Y y -1 is equal to and enlistment is
equal to 2 times X minus 3 squared we
can graph this and draw the foci or draw
the focus fairly fairly and actually
it's full size if there was more than
one focus let's see that's the x-axis
that's the y-axis where is its vertex
the vertex is at the point 3 comma 1 so
we go 1 2 3 comma 1 so that's its vertex
it's an upward-opening parabola because
this is a positive number actually we
don't even have to know that if you just
draw the focus and the directrix you
might be able to figure that out but
where is the focus point the focal point
is going to be 1 over 4a above this
point so 1 over 4 times 2 is equal to
1/8 so it's going to be the focal points
going to be really close it's going to
be right up here it's going to be 1/8
above our vertex
and then our directrix is going to be
1/8 below it so it's going to be right
there so the directrix is going to look
like this the direction is going to be
there the focal point is there and then
the graph of this line it's going to
look something like of this parabolas
going to look something like this so
anyway hopefully I didn't confuse you
too much and the whole point of doing
all of this is just to realize that it's
pretty easy to find the focus and the
directrix of a parabola if you have its
equation in this form you just take
whatever is multiplying times the X -
you know whatever squared term and you
essentially divide one by four times
this value and then you know the
distance from the vertex to the focus
and you know the distance from the
vertex to the directrix and you're all
done see in the next video